freunde der sonne wir haben etwas sehr
merkwürdiges aufzuklären nacht
hip-hop-musik käse fruchtiger käse
bekommt besonderen geschmack durch hip
hop branche mit käse hip hop macht
größere löcher und selbst die tagesschau
berichtete von der musikalischen käse
forschung danke an daniel an dieser
stelle der uns diese schlagzeile per
twitter zwitschert hat weil er sich
dachte also was passiert wenn ich käse
während der reifung mit musik beschallt
und kann ich diese musik am ende
wirklich schmecken das klären wir heute
in einer neuen ausgabe schlagzeilen
wissenschaftlich geprüft als musik soll
ja angeblich auf alles mögliche einen
einfluss haben auf das wachstum von
pflanzen auf das wachstum von babys
warum nicht auch auf käse
das fragen sich natürlich ein paar
schweizer und zwar an der hochschule der
künste in bern
es handelt sich hier nicht um ein
forschungsinstitut sondern um eine
kunsthochschule die machen regelmäßig
fancy kunstprojekte in den gemeinden
rund um beeren zum beispiel eine
klanginstallation in einem brunnen das
neue spray das auch ein kunstprojekt ist
aber ziemlich wissenschaftlich
aufgezogen wie bei einem ordentlichen
wissenschaftlichen experiment üblich
wurde hier eine hypothese formuliert die
hypothese lautet dass die
unterschiedliche bezahlung der
halbhartkäse zu unterschiedlichen
ausprägungen der sensorischen
eigenschaften der käse führt also auf
deutsch beschied man den käse mit musik
verändert das seinen geschmack eine
klare hypothese die man jetzt sehr schön
experimentell untersuchen kann hier die
tracklist zu diesem experiment könnt
musikstücke verschiedener genres von
klassik
[Musik]
und dann noch drei verschiedene sinus
töne das bedeutet drei reine töne
unterschiedlicher mit diesen insgesamt
acht verschiedenen sounds wurde jetzt
käse während der reifung beschallt in
solchen kisten die ja eigens dafür
gebaut wurden und am ende wurden die
verschiedenen käse von einer fachjury
geschmacklich beurteilt und dabei kam
heraus dass der hip hop käse
geschmacklich besonders hervorsticht so
war der hip hop käse besonders fruchtig
sowohl im geruch als auch im geschmack
und diese geschmackliche beurteilen
durch die jury die wurde auch nicht
irgendwie gemacht ohne eine beurteilung
erfolgte in anlehnung an eine konsens
profil prüfung gemäß din en iso 13849
mit dreistelligen zufallszahlen codiert
das heißt das ganze war verblindet das
klingt ja eigentlich alles ganz
wissenschaftlich das problem ist pro
sound wurde hier jeweils nur ein
käselaibe bescheid
es gab zwar noch einen kontroll käse
also ein referenz käse der im stillen
reifte aber auch hiervon gab es nur eine
dass mich dieses problem kurz ausführen
denn das ist jetzt ein ganz wichtiger
punkt für allgemeines wissenschaftliches
denken und arbeiten wie testet man eine
hypothese in der wissenschaft man kann
natürlich versuchen diese hypothese zu
belegen was man aber normalerweise macht
ist diese hypothese versuchen zu
widerlegen also wir halten es auch schon
mal für die hypothese der weihnachtsmann
existiert gibt es viele belege wie zum
beispiel die geschenke unterm
weihnachtsbaum oder die vielen bilder
und geschichten so lange wir nur billige
suchen geht die hypothese auf erst wenn
wir versuchen die hypothese zu
widerlegen indem man den weihnachtsbaum
heimlich beobachtet die ganze nacht um
zu sehen wer wirklich die geschenke
darunter legt erst dann haben wir die
hypothese wissenschaftlich geprüft das
bedeutet eine haltbare hypothese muss
nicht nur belegbar sein sondern sie muss
auch widerlegung versuchen stand also in
unserem käse fall können wir jetzt eine
sog
10 hypothese aufstellen die null
hypothese lautet es ist egal mit was für
einer musik der käse beschallt wird es
hat keinen einfluss auf den geschmack
und diese hypothese die muss man jetzt
versuchen noch zu widerlegen so wenn ich
jetzt diese acht verschiedenen sounds
habe und dafür acht verschiedene käse
leibe und noch einen referenzland einen
kontrolle
warum kann ich mit diesem
experimentellen setup die neue hypothese
nicht widerlegen weil käse und vor allem
schweizer käse ein naturprodukt ist und
naturprodukte unterliegen natürlichen
schwankungen die zusammensetzung
verschiedener naturprodukte ist nicht
exakt gleich und deswegen ist auch der
geschmack nicht exakt gleich beim käse
hängt die reifung von den
mikroorganismen ab die darin wachsen und
wer jetzt in seinem käsekeller an
verschiedenen ecken minimale
unterschiede bestehen in der temperatur
oder feuchtigkeit dann beeinflusst das
die aktivität dieser mikroorganismen und
selbst wenn man diese äußeren
bedingungen perfekt kontrollieren könnte
sind biologische prozesse exakt gleich
das bedeutet unter der annahme dass die
null hypothese war ist dass es unter der
annahme dass musik einen einfluss auf
den geschmack hat so werden verschiedene
käse laibe aus biologischen gründen
kleine unterschiede in der
zusammensetzung und im geschmack haben
und was war das ergebnis dieses
experiments es gibt unterschiede die
null hypothese ist mit diesem ergebnis
natürlich überhaupt nicht widerlegt
allein dieser versuchsaufbau war dazu
verurteilt am ende nichts auszusagen und
all die bemühungen das irgendwie
wissenschaftlich aufzuziehen
also sei es jetzt die milch die vom
selben baum stammt die karton teller
gibt den normen ja sie haben sogar die
verschiedenen käseproben einem
lebensmittelchemiker gegeben der sie
untersucht hat und zu dem unglaublichen
ergebnis kam es gibt unterschiede nein
doch immerhin steht folgender disclaimer
auf der website erstmal die unterschiede
sind allesamt eher klein und der
rückschluss dass diese unterschiede die
hypothese bestätigen das heißt eindeutig
auf die beschallung durch musik
zurückzuführen sind
ist denkbar aber nicht zwingend und um
herauszufinden ob eine eindeutige
kausalität zwischen der beschallung der
käse leider mit musik und sensorisch
wahrnehmbaren unterschieden besteht muss
ein größer angelegter versuch
durchgeführt werden was kann die
hochschule der künste in bern das
nächste mal besser machen erstens
braucht man nicht einen sondern viele
referenzklasse leibe die im stillen
reifen denn nur so kann man herausfinden
wie groß die natürlichen schwankungen
von leib zu bleibt in diesem keller zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt sind und am
besten hat man natürlich auch noch
mehrere käselaibe pro sound denn je
kleiner die zu erwartenden effekte desto
größer muss auch die stichprobe seien
damit wir diese effekte überhaupt sehen
können weiß welche da sind und
vielleicht wird ihr das experiment im
großen maßstab wiederholt denn bisher
wurde ja auch nicht widerlegt dass musik
einen einfluss auf die reifen haben
könnte ich würde jetzt keine großen
effekte erwarten aber schall ist
vibration und vibration könnte sowie
andere mechanische einflüsse
auswirkungen auf biologische prozesse
haben warum nicht zum beispiel sorgt
wind dafür dass pflanzen dicker und
stabiler wachsen unter sound
mikroorganismen beeinflusst das wurde
tatsächlich auch schon in der einen oder
anderen kleinen studie untersucht die
hypothese an sich ist also eigentlich
ziemlich bald jetzt endlich hip hop und
chemie ist immer nur gute kommen
jedenfalls ich bin ja für jede kuriose
forschung zu haben wenn wissenschaftler
aus rechnern mit welchem druck pinguine
kacken dann bin ich die erste die
darüber berichtet ihr kennt mich aber
wenn irgend ein kunstprojekt als
wissenschaft gekauft wird dann geht es
soweit nie aber im ernst dass dieses
kunstprojekt jetzt so wissenschaftlich
anmutend verkauft wird das ist die eine
sache aber das half ihr medien auch
seriöse darauf hereinfallen das ist
schon hart im letzten prüft die
schlagzeile video habe ich bereits die
pinguin studie erwähnt und viele von
euch haben geschrieben oh mein gott wo
finde ich diese geniale studie die
studie war inhalt meines aller ersten
youtube-videos dass verleger ich euch
findet ihr hier
hier kommt ihr außerdem zum letzten
prüft die schlagzeile video und wenn ihr
zu
kunst schlagzeilen sieht die über
unglaubliche wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse berichten und ihr euch
fragt dann teilt diese schlagzeile gerne
mit mir oder love auf twitter unter dem
hashtag prüft die schlagseite und dann
jetzt geprüft wir sehen uns nächste
woche bis dahin plötzlich